- My beloved Yale family,
wherever you might be,
I invite you to join me
in the spirit of prayer.
Almighty and loving
Creator, you are the force
that lights the stars, the
architect of every cell,
the source of all truth.
We look to you as many expressions
of one living mystery, a
mystery beyond all telling.
In this moment, we are people grieving
many different types of losses
and our hearts beat with
the rhythm of lament
as we cope with emotions too complex
for any of us to fully understand.
We who share this beautiful,
but aching, world,
we who look at the same
sun, and the same moon,
are a people called to
communal restoration.
As students of your
handiwork, we gathered at Yale
from throughout the earth
with exquisite ambitions
and have been blessed
at this place of light
and truth with the
freedom to let them grow.
Our God of all generations,
you are the guardian
of where we are going
and who we are becoming.
We are filled with
gratitude for our families,
friends, teachers, and guides.
Their arms have sheltered us,
their shoulders have boosted us,
and today their hearts
are holding fast to us.
Bless us as we seek to reimagine a world
made better by the considerable gifts
we will now bring to it.
May we exude an intelligence
that is inspired by justice,
guided by tenderness, moved by holiness,
and always informed by love.
As we greet tomorrow,
steady us on solid ground
and together may we become vibrant,
living examples of shalom, of
salaam, of shanti, of peace.
For this we say, amen.